we've been saying it over and over again
life is certainly more expensive for all
of us and to help give back eight news
now has partnered with albertsons to
help gift you a good day that's right
well every week we are surprising one
lucky shopper to help pay for their
groceries so let's take a look at how
john langler surprised one albertson's
shopper
[Music]
i met rachel at the albertsons in east
las vegas she told me prices for
everything has been a pain in her pocket
even though i'm retired military it
still pinches us i mean in the checkbook
so it's been very very challenging
because i know i i look at everything
on the shelves and how much they cost
and they have gone up so much to where
there's no way we can afford to go out
and live our lives because i want to go
out and buy more groceries only thing is
i know how much they cost so it's hard
to fill the pantry that's when
albertsons and eight news now decided it
was time to gift rachel a good day i
would like to gift you your groceries oh
my goodness wow what a blessing that is
good yes help pay for your groceries
this morning wow that is fantastic thank
you very much
rachel was so wonderful and appreciative
john tells us he had a great time
surprising her as well and you never
know you could be next keep an eye out
for the good day team maybe you'll be
the next person to be gifted a good day